How can I discern between feeling ill or sick, whether it's from detoxing or it's from a virus
or an infection or something? Yeah, that's hard because so, understand, so if I'm detoxing,
I can feel ill. That's typically called a herximer reaction, named after a doctor herximer who
initially described it a long time ago. I don't know what it was, but it's very common with people
with gram-negative bacterial infections that are killing that infection, like Lyme disease,
Lyme disease is a gram-negative bacteria, has gram-negative bacteria or has lipopolysaccharides
in the cell membrane. That's what makes it a gram-negative bacteria. And when you kill gram-negative
bacteria quickly, you will liberate a lot of lipopolysaccharides. And they're quite toxic,
and they can make a person feel quite ill. Lipopolysaccharides can damage the blood barrier very readily
and can cross the blood barrier and cause a lot of brain inflammation. It can make you feel really
yucky. That's called a herximer reaction. So when a detoxine, I can also feel ill. So a herximer
really is not specific to lipopolysaccharides, but it's specific to anything that overwhelms your
liver. So if I kill bacteria quickly, if I kill cells quickly, let's say with chemotherapy. So one
of the reasons why I feel so sick with chemotherapy is I'm taking a drug that's poisoned,
and that's killing all sorts of cells, and it can damage the blood barrier and cause inflammation
of the brain. But another reason is that it's killing cells pathologically, not through apoptosis,
but through cell lysis. So at any time you have cell lysis, pathological cell death,
you will liberate a lot of what are called endotoxins, cell particles, you know, cell membrane
junk, and you're going to overwhelm your liver. Your liver is like, I can't take anymore,
I can't take anymore. Go on, go on, go on. And you got all this junk in your blood, all these
endotoxins in your blood that can make you feel quite ill. Also, if you're sick, you have a virus,
you have a bacterial infection, you're going to feel ill. So how do I discern whether I
have a bacterial infection, have a virus, or I have a herximer reaction?
Sometimes it's difficult because you could get even a fever with a herximer reaction sometimes.
So typically, if you did a CBC with differential, that's a blood test, complete blood count.
I mean, it can be quite easy because that will show you if you're dealing with an infection
or you feel sick for some other reason. So that would be an easy way. So if we had access to
if you're in my hospital and you came in feeling empty, we'd do a CBC and a complete metabolic
animal with that CBC. If you showed an elevation of white blood cells over 7, 7.5,
I'd say you probably have an infection. And then you would look at the differential of this white
blood cells. And if you had a elevated neutrophil prepared to lymphocyte, I'd say you probably
have a little bacterial infection. I mean, if you have a very high white blood cell, I'll call it
let's say it's a 15. And you have an elevated neutrophil count compared to lymphocyte count. I'd
say maybe even need to consider getting an antibiotic. If you had an elevated white blood cell count,
like I said before, and an elevated lymphocyte count in a more suppressed neutrophil count,
I'd say you probably have a virus. You need to go home and drink some chicken soup and take
care of yourself. Either way, you probably should do that. So that's the easiest way to know
whether I'm feeling icky because I have an infection or I'm feeling icky because I'm detoxing.
But most of us don't just run off and get a blood test. It's just not that easy. Well,
we're not feeling well. So there's other clues. Other people in my house feel the same way.
Okay, that's a clue because you're not going to all be detoxing the same way.
You came from a party or you're exposed to a lot of people or you have more under a lot of stress
or you know, there's other things that would give you clues for that. Obviously, like I said,
if you have a fever, it's probably greater chance that you have a sickness from detoxing. If you're
throwing it up, you feel like you've got the flu. I mean, and then the other thing is if it passes
pretty quickly. So you had it for a couple days and now you're feeling better if probably was a bug
or something. So those are the things that I would use to help differential diagnosed between those two.